- Okay, new strategy,
don't ruin it too much.
(bouncy pop music)
- I am gonna be cutting
Steve's hair today.
- I am nervous that I'm gonna
cut too much of his hair off
and he's gonna be mad at me.
- (Jennifer) A short, Jake
Gyllenhaal-type style.
- (Safiya) This is what I picked out
for Tyler's ideal haircut.
I think we can pull this off.
- I am pretty, like,
particular about my hair.
- You're very particular about your hair.
- I get pretty stressed out.
I've been going to the same barber now
for about three years.
- As long as it doesn't
look like complete (bleep),
then I'll be okay with it.
Plus, I've got a couple of new hats
I'm looking forward to wearing.
- I'm not gonna get mad at her.
Unless she does a bad job.
(techno pop)
- Focus, all right, Jen?
- You gotta pick it up and then cut.
- No, I cut like this.
- No! No, you gotta pick
it up and then cut, okay?
You don't just shoot in there.
It's not an arts and crafts project.
- I feel like if I were to
pursue a different career
I could do hair.
- I'm glad that you feel
so casual about this.
(Jennifer laughs)
- Okay, babe, are you ready for the swoop?
- Oh, no no, hold on, hold on.
We really gotta game plan this one.
This is what you're gonna do.
You're gonna get the fingers out
and then you're gonna slice there.
- I feel like you've been
spending a little bit
too much time on the left
side, is that just me?
I don't know! I shouldn't
be directing you.
You're the one who can
see what's going on.
- You're right, I haven't
been this stressed
to get a haircut since I was three.
- Well, she stopped laughing, so ...
that's either good or bad.
- I love you, babe.
- I love you so much.
- (Tyler) Positive thoughts.
- I love you, too,
okay? Positive thoughts.
- One last look on this side. (laughs)
- Is it, oh, my God.
(buzzing)
- There's just like one
small bald spot. (laughs)
- No, there's not. There
is not a bald spot.
(Jennifer laughs)
- Oh, shit.
It's fine! Nothing happened!
So you know how surgeons
are trained, to like,
when they mess up, say "There"?
I'm just gonna start doing that. (laughs)
- You look good. (laughs)
- You know, you've said
I look good way too much
for me to believe that you
actually feel that way.
- Yeah, I think I'm done.
- This is the Jake Gyllenhaal,
courtesy of yours truly.
- Okay, it's not, eh, okay.
- It's not that bad.
- (Jennifer) It's pretty good!
(Tyler laughs)
- Um ...
That's not bad!
- I was expecting so
much worse, so, good job.
- Thank you, thanks.
- It's actually kind of dopey.
I mean, like, the sides,
it's not very good.
- Okay, fine.
- But, it's not ...
- What's ...
(pop music)
- I don't think I should
ever cut his hair ever again.
It's too stressful, and
if I had done any worse
I think we would've gotten into a fight.
- Would I let you cut my hair again?
Let's just say not in the next long time.
- Fair.
- I look like one of
those kids who just got
bubble gum stuck in his
hair and they're just like,
"We gotta get it out any
way possible," you know?
- What do you mean, on this side?
- Yeah, but I think it looks cool.
I mean, I'll grow into it.